der tik tok store younes macht für sie
war das neue studio es muss klar die
jungs dürfen lively satz als moderator
nicht für bosse
[Musik]
der optische neues dazu
das ideale kamera die kaum ein es gab
eben über vor dem muster werden falls
das ist bekomme ich aber eben immer ein
guter zeitpunkt dachte ich sogar ich
konnte influenza your für den dokfilm
generation self mit der kamera begleitet
damals ist er es nation als teenie idol
bekannt aufgrund zu siehe foto und film
dass soziale medien virtuell ein showman
im realen aber suchte younes donner
canetti von vor herzlich und leipzig
sowie eine zigarette raucht nach
autofahrer
rossing reserve sucht wurde das würde
ich jetzt tue sie finde mit dem unister
abstimmung am dritten november ich bin
positiv überrascht
der junge sich jetzt also
radiomoderatorin bekanntheitsgrad als
social media store hat vermutlich kurve
trotzdem er wo damals verloren wirkt hat
und sich nach dem abbruch der lehre aus
flak fachmann als influenza versucht hat
sind auch die jungs publikum
aufgestanden und habe schlafe jetzt mit
20 die jüngste rolle als teenie idol zac
wachse wie gott sie in der miet und wie
beurteilt der hüter hype um seine person
zusammen nur geht mir szene zu früh
[Applaus]
ja darf an ihnen
er brauchte bestätigt junis der unter
dessen 18 jahre alt geworden ist
präsentiert sich im neuen look mitbringe
und frisch aufgespritzten lippen
die sie zum glück zu rückgang mein gott
wie scheiße das käme sogar gut
ja ja krass was ich zeit habe ja die
ganzen jetzt auch privat gibt es für
anleger die junis ist frisch für die
haie weg vorbei in honig auf zürich lebt
marlow kann sich im juni mitbewohnerin
von 2 12 es gibt nur schrauben
christchurch sind am samstag und die
themen offen heißt kleider
das ist zwar technisch leider vor dem
rösten und drachen
das hat man ist einfach so auf die spur
wie fühlt sich das an
ein neuer lebensabschnitt
ich muss ehrlich sagt friedhof aber
jetzt vermessen langsam am morgen
absuche im land verhältnis von eunice zu
seiner mutter ist timo soini xxi
yunus der ohne vater aufwuchs legt heute
gemeinsam mit seiner mutter ihrem neuen
mann und dem kleinen halbbruder zusammen
vielleicht zu viel lieber mit sachen
geld einfach sachlich sachen sache mit
viel geld und es mehrfach aus von mir
würden die büro und
sie zerstören und einfach immer doppelt
im gespräch verrottete junis mehr biss
wurde damals im dok-film noch
verschwiegen hat fragt sie mich gefragt
wieso etui oder lehrpersonen mit anstand
xi hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
minute respektierter flach oder heimweg
sind ja vielleicht anbau mit ortszeit
mehr als werks haben kläger thema noch
mal anders im gegenteil man das
forsa-institut darfst du vorne zusammen
immer verlag raps soja chrysler
und im management und setzt sich also
ganz viel sprit
im juni seine sucht nach likes und
mechanik ich kann nachvollziehen warum
das so ist aber hat sich social media
mit dem was ich habe aus wie wenn der
[Gelächter]
zahn jedoch gemerkt dass das aber wie
gesagt nicht süchtig sein bsv die
bestätigung familien kollege von der
familie vor mehr sauberes wsb und was
ich sah der jung ist hat sie niveau mix
partnerin marlow wo eigentlich monika
roß sie heißt bin immer online
reality-format keine klemmt beide sind
sie kandidaten sie auch mal möchte mit
influenza geld verdienen
der us- hilft ihre debüt mit seinen rund
202 70 von ubisoft tik tok hatte junge
beachtliche und verdient pro werbepost
mittlerweile mehrere tausend franken
also für mich nichts vorhaben nicht
infrage kriegen wir es sind jetzt blöd
aber so ist ein normales bis fünf
geschafft und so wenn du wirklich das
zeug eine gut vermarktete dass ich habe
also das ist wie das was er weiß dass
sie karstadt mitverdienen und eigentlich
fans dass die fans wort und film sondern
es ist wirklich einfach dass sie
selbständig wort sie und für sich
glaubst du das was ich liebe
dies gab notiz an das sieht du hast ein
gleicher fans wählen und dann würde ja
das ist es soll ja social media blog
also ich wie eine zigarette raucht
machen versucht
doch was wichtig nach märz zeigen
öffentlich was dir erst kurz gespielten
treffern
es ist zwar schade dass es so krass wie
für andere ist das wenn ich male kraft
warum die landi die bank habe ältere
worte hilfe und service ist für uns
wichtig meine depressionen comeback
sachen ja einfach gemerkt hat dass das
ganze mehr einfach nur verbreitet und um
macht und man steht schon bald wurde
nicht so viel kluges zentrale machen
es schwingt mit wo ich jetzt gern mit
dem junis wirklich steht im dok-film hat
für schlagzeilen gesorgt
das thema sei es nicht so einfach das
erste scham ist privates regiocast starb
der junge hat gewusst dass die frau und
und ich im vorjahr wie verstandes sie
war es einfach kurz ausscheidet
schließlich ist es ja im film auch um
sie und gegangen wo nach der
ausstrahlung medienfragen hand hebe mir
jetzt erzählt halt die fürs büro und
ruhm
ein rückzieher gemacht das wird den
punkt ziegler ist das geld wird dass die
front row und stative störung des
schlafs monitor habe ich einmal öffnet
das lager von einem mysterium und drückt
so einfach wie es aussieht und ist am
grundweg wie junge liegt zeigt das ist
so befreiend rassy und so schön sie sei
einfach öffnen uns alte und man sagt was
sie denkt und wo schloss am ende hat man
und englisch und das unternehmen zeigt
das aber mittlerweile präsentiert sich
der junge sieht der online-welt
möglichst authentisch und gibt sich
gerne witze wo mit tik tok oft wachsen
ist findet das trotz videoplattform sich
negativ für andere baby und zu 67 68 und
kliniken
das sieht rufen sie uns einfach an sich
gestellt worden und hört merkt schnell
dass ich okay ich akzeptiert und
deswegen auf tape.tv
aber in lustiger art ist ein unterschied
wenn der sexualisierten minute also
folglich war das ist ja ich hab da oben
ohne idee baut hose also domain stars
das ja ja aber das komme die messe
findet es nicht schlimm also bei anderen
elemente nicht so lustig ist nur sucht
die junes hatte sich ein anderer
professioneller umgang mit der sozialen
medien
außerdem so ganz entzogen zwar ist
erwachsen wurde aber der unisys und
blieb das kind vor der generations für
die jungs ist tik tok mittlerweile sexy
wurde und er war sogar die soziale
medien in süchtig und krank gemacht was
sind eure erfahrungen und haben die
vielleicht sogar frage
dann schrieben kommentar